WHEN HOLLYWOOD SAYS NO, DON’T LISTEN
Scott Dunn, Writer/Director/Actor/Editor : Hi,
I’m Scott Dunn.
Gina Gomez Dunn, Producer/Actor: And I’m
Gina Gomez Dunn.
Scott: You know, I was thinking about something
today. I was in the kitchen looking at salt,
it made me think about today’s video. I
just thought about the first person...who
is the first person who is like “This, I
should sprinkle this on my food!” I thought
to myself, it was probably a caveman, right?
A caveman?
Gina: Probably.
Scott: [Grunts] Which means this is going
to taste good on my meat. And then I thought
there was probably another caveman and was
[Grunts]...which is “You can’t do that!
That’s a rock looking thing. You can’t
put that on your food. )
And imagine if the first caveman listened
to that negative caveman, we wouldn't have
salt all right.
We wouldn't have salt. Things taste better
with salt.
Now when you fast-forward to today and 2018
in Hollywood and there's cavemen all over
Hollywood who keep telling “You can't do
that. You can't do this. You can't do that.”
Gina: A lot of naysayers.
Scott: And we want to talk to you today about
our second feature film MANDAO OF THE DEAD
and all the things people say you can't do
and we did them anyway and if
we hadn't we wouldn't be sitting here with
a second feature film
So let's start...
Gina: Number One “You can’t make a movie
(especially a feature film for less than $100K”
or they won't take you seriously
Well our production budget for MANDAO OF THE
DEAD was just shy of thirteen
thousand. That's it. I round it up. You know
it's one of those things where you have to
work with what you got and tailor your script
to fit your budget and tailor your script
to things that you have available resources
that you have available to you.
Our co-producers Chessa Mehlman and Ian Sumner
graciously lent us their apartment. So we
saved a lot of money on the location.
Scott: Say half the movie was shot there so
right? There you know saving a lot of money
when I was writing the script for MANDAO I
made sure that we we stayed within the confines
of I knew how about how much money we had
to spend on this feature film and I thought
“Well I can write it in very few locations
but it doesn't but we didn't sacrifice any
fun.” I think it was about as fun it was
as it was ever gonna be and I actually think
that the limitations made it a better movie.
Gina: And even our crew, our sound mixer had
all his own equipment. Our DP had it's all
his own equipment and our associate producer
Oscar Munoz he lent us his camera gear so
it was like just see finding different ways
to save money without sacrificing quality.
Scott: Number two “It can't be done in nine
days? Not a feature film?”
And they were right it was done in ten days
so in that tenth day was really just a pick-up
day a pick-up day with a couple of additional
scenes after editing and I saw that there
needed to be a few things to fill in and ten
days is still crazy.
But again caveman! You bad caveman! You said
we couldn't do it. No, No!
Gina: The reason why we were able to do that
is we kept our crew cast and crew really small
so we were able to move fast and we also rehearsed
prior to shooting we've rehearse with an actor.
Scott: This is something that I'm very gung-ho
about. Always get the rehearsals going before
your movie that's where you know, that's where
you get to work on it because when you're
shooting you don't have time to explore as
much. You should know what you're doing and
you know you there's plenty of room for improvisation
on set.
I'm just saying do a lot of that work in the
rehearsals the third one...this is a personal
experience I had been in contact with a producer
in Hollywood and we were talking and we had
this sort of disagreement and he said to me
“You're not a writer. You're not a director.
I mean you're barely an actor and I remember
hearing that. It was obviously painful. It’s
painful to be told that you you're not something.
I had just done in the feature film, our first
feature film SCHLEP and it hadn't gotten into
any festivals yet. He's like “What festivals
was it has it gotten into? Yeah that's right,
nothing yet.”
And weirdly enough a week later we got accepted
to our First Glance Film Festival and we had
a great showing and the audience loved it
and it was just a nice thing where you know
I'm glad we didn't listen to people saying
no. I mean no one knows anything.
Gina: No one can tell you that you can't do
anything. I mean they can say it but don't
believe it for a second.
Scott: It can be really good. I will say after
all the time I've been in Hollywood it's been
10 years and I will say this it's about how
you receive words like that. If you people
say you can't do it, you have really two options:
believe them or show them and I think it was
actually I'd like to thank that guy because
it pushed me to really prove him wrong.
Scott: the fourth thing this is an interesting
one I edit my features we've done - I've edited
both.
Gina: Okay so so just to recap he Scott wrote
directed starred and now edited MANDAO OF
THE DEAD.
Scott: Gina and I like doing it but also it
saves money. Obviously you know how what our
budget is it helps save money but I also enjoy
doing it I think that who could know the movie
better than me at this point but a lot of
people were you know when I was asking on
SCHLEP like what should I do is SCHLEP was
my first movie so I was like oh should I edit
I get someone else and a lot of people like
you shouldn't edit your own you know you'll
be too close to it and no it's just not how
it's done and I remember thinking yeah but
I want to I feel like doing it it's not like
I ever felt burdened by it and it's like who
knows the movie better than you right exactly
and so going into this MANDAO feature I I
felt galvanized incompetent in editing it
and and I think this is something I'll be
carrying forward to future features because
it's just fine and and you know editing really
it's direct writing is one thing directing
is another thing editing is another thing
like if you can do all that that as a director
the more I think you'll be more enriched as
an
artist it's also staying true to your own
voice like how did you envision this movie
well if you're the writer director and editor
you know you get the last say in everything
Gina: So it really the film really became
Scott's voice and also they said don't do
don't use Final Cut Pro I mean everyone's
using Adobe and I again or avid and and that's
true a lot of people are using that and and
there's no problem with that and the only
problem is when people say you don't use Final
Cut Pro I'm like hi yeah if you can tell me
why great if not then that kind of information
that it's just so because I don't do it but
we did it anyway and it turned out great
Number five oh yeah you can't make money self
distributing your film or in other words you
need a distributor to make money making your
film that's just not true so for the majority
people if you're really indie you're making
your first feature it behooves you to self
distribute because each platform like iTunes
Amazon etc they take a percentage of all the
sales that you make then the distributor takes
another 30 percent 20 30 whatever yeah after
that it's like then you start seeing some
money and by that point it's like that's a
long time that's a lot of percentages to be
taking out before you see any money and and
and in this case of MANDAO OF THE DEAD and
SCHLEP we are putting our own money into it
we're putting our time sweat equity all these
things into it and it's like why give that
percentage away especially in a day and age
where you can distribute yourself yeah you
may I think we're trying to out BlumHouse
the BlumHouse model they they make movies
for very cheap right and then they make between
like they make a ton back I mean the margins
on their profits are I mean they're it's amazing
so we're doing that but crunching it down
even further we're talking like $13,000 that's
insane but it also means that you have more
of a chance of making your money back and
going into black you know I'm making a profit
with your money and that's me that's attractive
to me so I would suggest let's not let's not
let people
tell us no when they don't even they haven't
even tried it try it you'll see for yourself
Number six film school now it's not like people
said you can't do this you didn't go to film
school but it's not like we didn't feel that
I mean I'm survival like oh you guys didn't
go to film school so like yeah I'm just gonna
make a movie I'm not gonna say sit here and
say don't go to film school cause if you went
there that's great you're gonna learn so much
and it's it's probably really good to go to
film school however don't let that stop you
if you haven't been there be smart surround
yourself with people who who know what they're
doing who brings something to your movie don't
don't be so in your own head about you know
I'm the director only I have I had the last
say of course you have the last say but everyone
on your set is it if you got the right people
they're artists they have good ideas they're
smart you they're not trying to screw with
your they're trying to help you bring your
vision get a good team together so that you
can make the best product that's that I give
credit to everyone on our movie yeah I mean
the vast majority of our crew went to film
school so they have that technical knowledge
and stuff
thank goodness teachers which is great we
needed it but they it was fun to
collaborate with them so yeah so if you haven't
been in a film school so yeah you know if
you have a passion you have an idea if you
have something you can't get rid of from your
head go make it surround yourself with smart
people yeah I will say that there's just no
excuse you can make your own movie you can
shoot it on an iPhone you can get really really
micro budget and make a really good movie
it just all depends on what resources you
have available to you what kind of people
will kind of do you have it comes back to
there's a lot of cavemen in Hollywood mm-hmm
don't let those negative cavemen tell you
no.
Okay otherwise well we wouldn't have salt
right if we listen to all the times
people said you can't do that this world would
be one boring place to live all you filmmakers
out there who who are waiting for permission
I would ask you just don't wait okay bad caveman
bad listen to the caveman who made the salt
you.